como criar super agentes de maneira
gratuita rápida que vão responder o seu
WhatsApp eles vão poder vender eles vão
poder ah negociar por você eles vão
poder resolver problemas dos seus
clientes problemas seus pessoais ou
talvez você queira criar uma versão sua
de agente que fica respondendo a sua
família o tempo todo no seu WhatsApp
pessoal não importa o que você quer
fazer seja um SDR seja um copywriter
seja um atendente seja um vendedor seja
o que for aqui vai ser o seu primeiro
passo para fazer isso em poucos minutos
e sem complicação então o que você tá
vendo aí na sua frente agora é a tela do
Super Agente Super Agente é a empresa
que eu criei para criação de Agentes de
forma simplificada a ideia aqui é dar
super poderes para vocês todos que estão
me escutando aqui todas as pessoas que
me acompanham finalmente poderem começar
porque é uma das principais perguntas
que eu recebo é ah nossa tu fala sobre
agentes mas como fazer isso é difícil
envolve programação Nossa eu tenho que
usar um monte de ferramenta diferente
para fazer isso sim tudo essas eu tinha
que dizer sim para todas essas mas não
mais agora você vai conseguir em uma
ferramenta só e de graça criar isso Como
assim de graça sim porque a gente deixou
o plano aqui onde você consegue criar o
agente integrar ele com WhatsApp 100% de
graça você só paga aqui os outros planos
Se você começar a ganhar dinheiro com
isso senão você tá aqui usando a
ferramenta de graça que que a gente você
precisa para poder começar precisa de um
e-mail válido e Bom basicamente é isso
para começar você precisa de um e-mail
válido é tão fácil assim então vou
clicar aqui em
começar ó ele vai logar porque eu já tô
logado na minha conta eu vou deslogar e
vou criar uma conta do zero Então vou
colocar um e-mail
aqui
.ai fazer login ele vai mandar um e-mail
para mim deixa eu abrir o meu e-mail
academia lendária academi lendária deixa
abr de novo aqui atualizar
aqui pronto recebi vou clicar agora em
fazer login então entrei aqui primeira
coisa que vai aparecer aqui é que você
já tem esse botão de criar a gente mas
você vai notar que vai tá escrito assim
ó nenhuma llm configurada por quê para
você criar uma conta aqui você precisa
ter uma llm o que que é isso é um modelo
de linguagem ah
grande né um grande modelo de linguagem
que basicamente Algum serviço de api que
é api é uma chavezinha que você vai
pegar no site Inclusive eu vou te
mostrar como você pode pegar de graça
acesso a essa api então um dos Sites que
eu gosto muito de pegar API de graça
deles que é muito boa é o grock o grock
você entra aqui eu vou logar você loga
de graça aqui ó fazer o seguinte mais
fácil ainda vou entrar aqui configurar
aqui vai eu posso configurar várias APS
diferentes então e olha uma curiosidade
interessante tá eu ó de semana fui fazer
uns cálculos se você paga por exemplo
por um serviço eu peguei a média do
serviços brasileiro de Agentes que tem
aqui para criação de Agentes eles te
goem por crédito Sabe quantas vezes mais
eles estão ganhando em cima dos créditos
da op mais de 1200 vezes exatamente mais
de 1300 vezes o crédito mais ou menos aí
Ah que essas empresas cobram fica em
torno de , me tá por crédito só que na
op e tu pega vamos pegar o valor mais
alto de todos que é 60 60 centavos de
dólar multiplica por por cinco né que é
o o mais ou menos o dólar aqui no Brasil
e daí você vai ter ali R 3 tá r$ 3 por 1
milhão de tokens 1 milhão de créditos
divide R 3 por 1 milhão Tu vai ter
0,003 Então olha só quanto eles ganho em
cima então aqui você vai poder não
precisa
ah pagar por créditos você pega uma
chave eu clico aqui ó vai abrir ah
diretamente o site da da do grock vai
verificar se eu sou humano verific ficou
beleza aqui eu crio por exemplo vou
criar uma nova chave nova chave aqui
você bota o nome que quiser super
agentes etc vai criar aqui eu
copio venho aqui clico em editar e colo
pronto tá resolvido você já tem agora a
sua llm a sua o seu a sua ia de graça
para trabalhar aqui dentro fez isso
vamos criar o agente agora então eu
venho aqui clico em criar agente aqui eu
vou escrever aqui eu vou criar um agente
de suporte suporte aos alunos aqui eu
vou botar a descrição
faz suporte do meu curso de
criação de Agentes de
superagentes no superagentes P Inclusive
eu vou gravar um curso inteiro sobre
super agentes pra galera que acessa isso
aqui Criou já vai cair nessa tela que é
a tela que onde você vai gerenciar o seu
gente você clica aqui em configurações
você clica aqui em modelo você vai poder
escolher o modelo Conforme você integrou
aqui com grock Então você vai poder
escolher o modelo Lhama 70b beleza só
isso agora vem para prompt em prompt
você pode descrever o seu agente aqui né
O que é o seu agente ele é de suporte o
que que o seu agente faz Qual os
objetivos é só digitar aqui gente e ele
já vai criar aqui se você quiser colocar
regras para ele como por exemplo não
fale tal coisa quais temas você deve
evitar né assuntos que ele deve evitar
quais assuntos quais palavras ele deve
evitar e aqui você pode adicionar regras
específicas né além de links permitidos
para ele poder falar ou seja você vai
adicionando aqui os links ó e esses
links ele pode indicar só o que acontece
se você clicar aqui em importar template
olha só a gente já tem um de suporte ao
cliente a gente tem também aqui o prompt
avançado que basicamente aqui você tá
livre para escrever o que você quiser
aqui simplificado você segue né o nosso
padrão mas se você vier aqui ó e clicar
em suport ao cliente pum e já cri cria
aqui todo o suporte ó o que faz e tudo
mais daí eu venho aqui e digito aqui ó
suporte cender da empresa aqui eu vou só
só coloca o nome né da empresa ó aqui é
superagentes você possui aqui vou botar
quantos anos de experiência né vou botar
que ele possui 5 anos de experiência
Ah beleza aqui eu posso botar onde é que
ele é certificado se eu quiser que ele
interage de uma determinada maneira Ah
eu vi agora que minha tela também em
cima aqui deixa eu botar pro outro lado
aqui pronto deixa eu dar um zoom também
para ficar mais fácil pra galera que
acessa às vezes do celular pronto então
agora
sim
então agora o que você vai fazer aqui
basicamente você edita né isso aqui ah
tudo que você achar importante digitar
praticamente está pronto para vocês aqui
ó o prompt Então você vai ler ele como
seesse texto mesmo mas se você quiser
botar links aqui para base de
conhecimento para suporte né a ideia que
ele seja um suporte as regras que você
tem basicamente eu vou só salvar aqui
porque o promt está pronto eu só seria
só editar isso você faz de forma bem
rápida né agora tem uma questão assim tá
aqui o prompt ó todo certinho Vamos
botar ele no WhatsApp então primeira
coisa que eu vou fazer tá pronto o
agente ah Alan dá para melhorar ele
Claro dá para melhorar você pode colocar
banco de dados esse ag gente você pode
botar informações nele mas eu quero ir
pros pros próximos passos já que são as
perguntas que as pessoas me mandam muito
que é como colocar no WhatsApp você vai
clicar em publicar Você vai clicar aqui
adicionar e assim eu vou usar aqui aqui
o Evolution porque ele é digamos
gratuito né você instala no servidor ele
é gratuito aqui a gente vai ter mais uma
feature em breve que vai ser você vai
ler o QR Code e deu acabou mas por
enquanto não por enquanto você precisa
de um serviço externo seja api oficial
seja US api ou seja Evolution api vou
clicar aqui vai gerar um webhook para
mim né Ah aqui no Evolution e se você tá
aí se perguntando o que você faz com
essa URL não se preocupa eu vou te
mostrar agora como você vai configurar
ela no Evolution Então deixa eu
compartilhar de novo minha tela aqui ah
já tá configurado Evolution nesse vídeo
aqui eu não vou mostrar como configurar
o Evolution Ah eu vou simplesmente
mostrar para vocês aqui Como configurar
os superagentes dentro do Evolution até
porque a ideia é que evolution ou
superagentes em breve esteja totalmente
integrado com Evolution que você não
precise ah instalar ele uma máquina mas
para que você possa estar Ah como é que
tu tem isso aí esse Evolution instalado
eu instalei numa máquina minha num
servidor eu pago acho que ó o8 dólares
por mês em servidor mas a ideia é que
você tenha tudo dentro do superagentes
enquanto isso enquanto você não tem uma
das ideias é você usar aqui né o o
Evolution Então vou vir aqui criar uma
Instância Vou colocar aqui o nome Alan
eu vou testar no meu número
Pessoal pessoal aqui é só para você se
identificar o que que é eu vou botar
bailis aqui tá uma chave de api clico em
salvar pronto primeira coisa que eu
preciso fazer agora é conectar o meu
celular então vou vir aqui peguei aqui
meu celular então você pega aí o seu
celular tá vem aqui na parte de onde é
que você vai vir aqui no celular você
vai vir no WhatsApp você vai clicar em
configurações tá então vai lá em
configurações vai lá em dispositivos
conectados e clica aqui no botãozinho
Verde conectar então clica em conectar
vai aparecer essa tela aqui que é para
ler o QR Code você lê o q code aqui
pronto pronto tá atualizado clico
aqui agora vamos vir aqui pegar essa
RL voltamos aqui vamos web Hook clica
aqui na URL adiciona URL clica aqui você
vai clicar aqui ó messages upsert é só
esse evento que você vai botar clica
aqui em webhook base 64 clica em
habilitado então só isso clicou em
salvar pronto gente tá integrado é isso
é isso que você precisa fazer para
integrar o WhatsApp com superagente
tendo Evolution instalado acesso a ele
você vai vir aqui adicionar o número
pega o URL e coloca aqui mensagens obser
web Hook base né mostrando de novo aqui
minha tela ã Ah eu tava com minha imagem
em cima ótimo professor que Parabéns uh
então aqui ó eu tava mostrando como é
tela em cima Então você vai botar aqui
em URL vai botar em message weert vai
clicar aqui em web Hook e deixa aqui
clicado inabilitado e salva é só isso é
esse é o passo a passo uma vez estando
assim agora vou testar então eu vou vou
pegar aqui o meu
novamente vou conectar para você ver
aqui no meu navegador a minha o meu
celular
pessoal pronto e vou mandar uma mensagem
para mim mesmo nesse número aqui então
Ó
ncolas Olá tudo bem Você de novo por
aqui
mandei eu já tinha feito alguns testes
antes você vai ver que tem mensagens
aqui trocadas mandei a mensagem
aqui é isso cliquei em finalizar posso
vir aqui em
conversas conversas então Ó você por
aqui ele já me respondeu sim estou aqui
para ajudá-lo em qualquer problema
pergunta que você tem hoje se eu venho
aqui ó ele já aqui sou eu né eu mesmo
então já eu recebi aqui mensagem e aqui
ele mesmo respondeu o WhatsApp então já
tá funcionando a nossa integração já tá
funcionando o nosso agente aqui com
o nosso nossos superagentes as dois já
estão integrados agora a gente vai pra
próxima etapa que é os integração de
conteúdos agora como você acabou de ver
aqui nós vamos recapitular um pouquinho
a gente já tem um agente criado ele já
está integrado no WhatsApp então já tá
funcionando você manda mensagem no
WhatsApp ele responde o que que a gente
quer agora a gente quer customizar esse
agente como a gente vai fazer isso a
gente pode adicionar uma por exemplo um
banco de conhecimento o que que é um
banco de conhecimento a gente pega
informações que só esse agente
basicamente vai ter porque não estão na
internet ou se estão na internet não a
ia não foi treinada com base nessas
informações para que o agente possa se
lembrar para que ele tenha uma memória
sobre as informações da sua empresa da
pessoa que você tá clonando seja o que
for Então o que eu quero te mostrar
agora é como você vai pegar esse
conhecimento né que existe por exemplo
de uma um suporte Então o que eu quero
que ele tenha acesso vamos ver junto
isso deixa eu compartilhar minha tela
aqui de novo então vou vir aqui ó ã
posso vir aqui em conteúdo criar um novo
conhecimento vou chamar aqui ó ã
eu vou chamar tipo assim conhecimento do
suporte ou suporte posso botar uma
descrição aqui marcar público é quando
eu quero fazer acessar esse esse data
Store esse banco né esse banco de
conhecimento através de Outras
aplicações outras ferramentas e tal isso
aqui é mais avançado Eu até vou acho que
vou tirar isso da dessa dessa dessa área
aqui porque para não confundir vocês vou
tirar daqui vou deixar lá em avançado
beleza criei tá vazio então eu vou botar
uma nova fonte de conhecimento que que
eu posso adicionar posso funar
basicamente qualquer coisa tá texto
perguntas e respostas arquivo página web
e pensando em página web se eu for abrir
aqui a página dos superagentes já tem
algumas informações aqui
ó então eu vou adicionar essa página e
tem outra também interessante que é
deixa eu ver se como funciona também tá
aqui mas existe essa aqui ó que é o a
documentação dos superagentes então eu
vou mandar essa para ele para ele pegar
porque ele vai conseguir entrar em todas
as subpáginas e lê tudo então vou vir
aqui e clico aqui ó página site porque
página ele vai serir só uma página única
e essa aqui é só uma página única né
Essa do superagentes Mas essa aqui é um
site tem várias páginas intern Então vou
vir aqui site venho aqui e coloco a URL
aqui URL do site map não eu quero o URL
do site mesmo vamos ver se ele vai pegar
assim mesmo Ah aqui a gente vai botar
aqui né
documentação e Ah aqui tem um adicionar
link ó não link da Blacklist ou seja uma
url que eu não quero que ele Leia vou
enviar al faz sentido botar tags aqui as
tags servem para principalmente para se
guiar ah a gente não tá usando elas T
tanto na parte da inferência na parte de
hag Ah o que que é inferência que que é
hag Não se preocupa só Ignore só vem
aqui ó já tá executando ele tá rodando
aqui lendo todas as páginas e criando
todo o banco de dados para você de
informação enquanto isso Ó já 21 páginas
e tá anexando elas Enquanto isso vamos
adicionar mais uma fonte que daí vai ser
uma página Web que daí vai ser o
superagentes para ele extrair tudo que
tem
aqui vamos vir aqui adicionar e aqui vou
botar página
inicial página página
inicial beleza enviar salvou ó tá
sincronizando aqui e aqui também então
se eu clicar aqui inclusive vou ver o
que ele já pegou ó ele já pegou várias
páginas ó da documentação Então vou
entrar aqui em alguma PTE da
documentação que tem uma coisa muito
específica que nem aqui ó esse documento
comendo termos de uso
tá ah como todo aqu se refire a pessoa
física pegar uma coisa muito específica
que vai est escrito aqui que não vai ter
na
internet aqui
ó o que são os conhecimentos dos
superagentes eu vou perguntar isso para
ele e agora que a gente já tá aqui né eu
vou fazer o teste aqui mesmo você pode
vir aqui no agente clica aqui nesse
botãozinho e tu vai conversar aqui com
ele Ó então ó me
explique o que são os conhecimentos dos
superagentes Então tá aqui ó já me
trouxe aqui as informações só a base de
informações habilidades que o
especialistas atendimento do suporte
nível como eu utilizam para fornecer
soluções personalizadas e eficazes com
clientes daí me trouxe tudo aqui ó é um
recurso interno que contém informações
detalhadas e tudo mais legal já me
trouxe informações ó e vamos ver aqui ó
que que tá escrito aqui facilmente seus
dados personalizados sear ser utilizados
vaiando Super Agente
personalizado legal ele já me trouxe
informações agora o seguinte eu quero
que ele me referi quando eu perguntar
assim como estudar sobre superagentes né
Onde eu posso
estudar onde posso estudar sobre o
superagentes
vamos ver o que ele vai me dizer para
aprender mais sobre superagentes você
pode consultar a base de conhecimento ou
portal de suporte ao cliente ou seja
tutoriais vídeo foras da comunidade
porque eu não configurei isso né eu não
configurei aqui o meu superagente que é
um suporte para me responder Com base no
que eu quero então eu vou configurar
agora para você ver como ele já vai
melhorar a resposta Ah E lembrando que
eu eu tô usando um modelo bem digamos é
de graça esse modelo né o 70b Se eu
colocar o GPT
4oo mini as respostas são ainda melhores
Mas vamos lá eu vi aqui e vou vir aqui
em prompt e vou alterar porque aqui tá ó
aqui é só um template para vocês né e eu
não ateria esse template o certo aqui é
de ficar um tempo ajustando ó
conhecimento da das abordagem marcado
pel empatia paciência aqui tu vai
escrever do jeito que tu quer né aqui eu
posso escrever por exemplo sua abordagem
é marcada
por mensagens diretas e engraçadas
beleza só resolver problema de forma á
personalizada diagnosticar problemas
técnicos tem aqui a parte das URL quer
ver ó aqui ó fórums tutoriais em vídeo
Bas Por isso ele tá falando essas coisas
ó então aqui ó eu vou botar documentação
né e vou botar o canal do YouTube
recursos aqui
ó
documentação e aqui eu vou botar o link
da documentação
para el avisar a pessoa que ela pode
acessar a documentação quando ela quiser
ter informações né e vou botar aqui
também meu canal no
YouTube canal
no YouTube Alan
ncolas vou pegar aqui o meu canal deixa
pegar aqui o RL daí ele vai indicar meu
canal também quando a pessoa quiser
aprender aqui
então deixar
aqui
pronto aqui eu vou dizer aqui aqui estão
alguns links para
indicar quando alguém perguntar por onde
estudar
o
superagentes Só isso tá vou salvar
aqui agora vou vir aqui vou perguntar no
WhatsApp lá vou vir abrir meu WhatsApp
aqui e vou perguntar aqui
ó como
ah como posso aprender mais sobre o
super agentes eu vou botar aqui vou
compartilhar minha tela com você até
escrevi errado aqui
superagentes vamos ver
aqui eu também consigo ver as ó o que tá
acontecendo ó aqui ó já consigo ver aqui
essa conversa ó para aprender mais sobre
subagentes você pode consultar
documentação em Além disso o canal do
YouTube do Alan ncolas é uma ótima fonte
de informação dicas valiosas se eu abro
aqui meu WhatsApp tá aqui para aprender
mais sobre superagentes você pode
consultar a documentação hein Além disso
você pode aprender mais com entendeu E
aqui ele já tem as informações também
dos bancos de dados então se eu
perguntar alguma coisa que só tá aqui ó
ah é possível aqui ó isso aqui deve
estar no banco de dados é possível criar
um agente do zero mesmo que eu seja
iniciante eu vou fazer essa pergunta
aqui para você comprovar que tipo ele tá
sendo acesso a um banco de dados para
poder responder isso vou vir aqui em
conversas por que que é interessante vir
aqui né aqui ó porque você vou mostrar
isso que é interessante ã
é
possível é possível criar Agentes do
zero mesmo seja
iniciante ó sim é possível crag arm
iniciante para isso você pode começar a
aprender sobre superagentes através da
base de conhecimento do portal Além
disso você pode tutoriais enf participar
do fórum e tudo mais
ã então ele tá trazendo já as
informações daqui né e eu posso até
olhar aqui o banco de dados no banco de
dados de conteúdo aqui ó vamos ver se
ele tem as fontes aqui Fontes tá tá aqui
ó página inicial ele já conseguiu pegar
tá aqui ó o que ele extraiu eu consigo
ver também se eu vir aqui ó em
documentos eu consigo ver também quais
documentos ele extraiu né se eu clicar
aqui ó eu consigo ver certinho a
documentação e o que que ele extraiu na
documentação então todo toda a
informação ele é extraída né aqui no no
banco de conhecimento e aqui no agente
você vai começar agora só ajustar você
vem aqui né em prompt avançado e faz os
ajustes necessários aqui a já entregou
para você template para que você possa
ajustar a medida que você vai fazendo
testes aí vai verificando ó beleza ele
tá mizando os links ele tá me trazendo
informações Ah eu quero integrar com o
meu banco de dados quero integrar com
outras coisas isso é mais avançado eu
vou gravar outros vídeos aqui para vocês
no YouTube também mostrando como fazer
integrações com banco de dados com apis
né do superagentes já é possível fazer
isso mas aqui esse vídeo a ideia seria
Exatamente Essa assim de uma introdução
para vocês ah da criação de um agente
integrado com WhatsApp
E como você pode já adicionar documentos
eu posso adicionar por exemplo um canal
no YouTube inteiro e ele pegar tudo
Inclusive eu vou criar aqui um clone
para vocês faz o seguinte vamos
interagir aqui nesse nesse vídeo eu
quero entender o que vocês querem também
sei vocês querem saber de SDR clonar
então faz o seguinte comenta aqui
embaixo qual tipo de clone ou SDR ou
vendedor o que você quer que eu crie
aqui para eu criar se você quer que eu
crie o clone de alguém me diga aqui quem
um youtuber ver ou algum escritor Porque
daí eu vou pegar e vou subir os os os
livros dele os canais deles do YouTube
para você ver ele funcionando ele
funcionando como se fosse aquela pessoa
se você pudesse clonar alguém para ficar
no seu WhatsApp aí no WhatsApp de alguém
quem você clonar então o seguinte se
você gostou desse vídeo já deixa o like
se inscreve se você go quer ver mais
coisas aqui do super agentes como criar
agentes E não esqueça também de deixar
seu comentário Eu quero saber que tipo
de agente você gostaria que eu criasse
aqui essa aqui foi só uma aula
introdutória um vídeo introdutório para
que você entenda como é fácil e vai
ficar ainda mais fácil Essa aqui é só a
primeira versão a gente já tá preparando
para que você possa integrar diretamente
no WhatsApp aqui sem precisar do
Evolution externo sem precisar de apis
externas mas caso você precise eu vou
deixar também aqui nos links um vídeo
tutorial para instalar o Evolution assim
você instala o Evolution utiliza aqui os
superagentes e consegue usar tudo de
graça sem pagar nada por isso e claro
claro você evoluindo né você querendo
utilizar mais recursos quar mais gente a
gente tem os planos aqui que são bem em
conta também hoje nossos planos eu final
de semana como eu falei para você no
começo do vídeo eu cheguei a fazer uma
análise dos planos concorrentes a nível
Internacional e eu percebi que como a
gente não cobra por token a gente custa
aí uns 90% mais barato que qualquer
outra empresa que fornece Tecnologias
para criação de Agentes Então você vai
est muito bem assegurado aqui com a
gente tendo o melhor custo benefício e
tendo muita muita inovação porque isso
aqui é só o começo te vejo no próximo
vídeo